tom cruise
tom cruise
[Music]
tom cruise apparently went ballistic on
someone let's listen to it oh yeah and
just as a little bit of
context he got mad at some crew members
on set apparently because they were
not following proper guidelines uh you
know because we have a pandemic going on
and
anything you get this movie shut down if
you don't follow the proper guidelines
so
i'm already on his side just putting
that out there it's biased
making movies right now because of us
because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every studio at
night
insurance companies
they're looking at us and using us to
make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
i don't ever want to see it again
[Music]
that's it and you do and you can
and you i want to know what's going on
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education
[Music]
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you
and now i'm dead and if you don't do it
you're out
we are not shutting this down
is it understood my god if i see it
again you're
going and sure you so you're gonna cost
him his job
and i see it on the set you're going and
you're going
did i miss anybody that's it
am i clear do you understand what i want
you
understand the responsibility that you
have
because i will deal with your reason
damn i would not mess with this guy
ever no not even a little bit
what is it
i trust you guys to be here
that's it
that's it we're good so it's solid yeah
we're done right
that's a wrap right that's right that's
right it's a great job did you get the
get the audio of that is everyone so
quiet you got the audio right okay good
it'll make me look like a hero let's go
let's go people are forgetting all about
those guys for real all right
[Applause]
public relations wow you know i i never
took the mass thing seriously but i will
now guys
i yeah i know i will like that i never
want to have
that be pointed at me he sounded so mad
god i love league celebrity angry tapes
you're the best
yeah man he's he he goes to sleep with
the entire movie industry on the phone
with him every night didn't do it
mission impossible
is gonna do it we are gonna save movie
theaters and the film production
business
and everything above you know i think we
gotta listen to it again i think i think
we just got everything
double whammy on this one get these very
obviously gosh
you know it's nice to get another leaked
celebrity angry audio
come on i mean he's going he's going
pretty crazy it's nice to hear some
people be raided he's going
he's going mad he's going ballistic he
is laying the law down but you know what
he's fighting the good
fighters he's fighting the good fight
uh yeah this is the most justifiable
rant i'm pretty
sure he's make some points be safe
we are the gold standard oh that's the
best opening we are the gold standard
making movies right now because of us
because they believe in us and what
we're doing
we are creating thousands of goods
because sometimes it sounds like he's
getting like motivating and
inspiring that he's just like
[ __ ]
that's it and you do sometimes it sounds
like an inspirational speech and then
it's just like
brainy that's how inspiring is
it's how motivated he is your apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their see like i
i get where he's coming from man yeah
i love these pictures they've chosen to
future of this
relies on me and everything about me
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies
i have told you guys
it's not wrong i mean i'm sure because
this is in production a lot of other
productions are feeling
safe to go and yeah and a lot of people
could lose their
jobs like and this could affect the
industry
it's a huge movie
that's it am i clear
do you understand what i want you
understand
the responsibility tom cruise needs to
go into like a a a freaking like
political speech or something
he needs to go to a to have a town hall
meeting what do you need to wear your
mess
wear your masks why aren't you wearing
your mouse
that's it guys that's that's all i just
slept
i just imagine a guy who's had so much
pressure to deal with
and have to be cool yeah you see those
videos of him
interacting with like fans and stuff on
set
he's like so he's the tom cruise polite
charming kind selfie is
and from everyone who's like talked
about working with him he he takes his
work seriously
obviously um but he's most part a
gentleman
i just imagine like this has just been
so stressful to make sure
and i'm so happy to know that he is
doing his absolute best
to ensure that they are following
guidelines i
i actually have respect is this the best
way to have handled the situation
yes yes a hundred percent you must
because not only is that crew gonna
listen but probably a lot of other
random people in the world
just for fear that tom cruise is gonna
pop up and berate the [ __ ] out of you
for not wearing your mask if you're
standing too close or whatever
and i mean he is not wrong he's not
wrong about what he's fighting for he's
not wrong about that because it
is in a way like yeah it's an industry a
lot of people need to work but it's also
a fragile
somewhat privilege that it's possible at
all and so
while yeah i agree maybe a little calm
could have helped maybe
the public image of this it's also like
yeah i mean at the end of the day the
virus doesn't care in these safety
protocols for a large consortium
like a mission impossible movie it has
such a huge crew that yeah like this
shit's important saying let's
love it weird they're gold gold it
sounds
so ridiculous it's so funny but then
you think about it and you're like well
yeah they have to
they have to do the gold standard
protocol in order to keep afloat tom's
gonna risk his life
and the more movies that can continue to
pull this
off by following the guidelines the more
movies can get made
it's literally trying to lead by example
just by running a smooth
set i'm under the impression someone
like this to be like look how much of a
terrible human he is when i walk away
going
he's not he's right maybe he's
overreacting is it right to
call to call people these names and
insult them no but i
also agree it crosses into that sort of
like christian bale as
cartooniness of like i i understand how
upset you are but also it's
this is kind of no you know what like
all right some people are gonna get mad
at us for
having so much fun with this whatever
get mad
i'm on tom cruise's side hey yeah i
don't know
he's gotta eat absolutely i'm on his
point and that's what everyone signed up
for homeboy i'm on your side tommy
we got you we got you such a sexy man
he is even when he's angry i've worked
my ass off to get my career back on
track
this is the only thing i have to do my
name right now franchise the same
dark universe i'm gonna screw me over
you guys
the one thing i have control over that
everyone in the world seems to agree on
do you agree with tommy leave your
thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell this is
refreshing this is refreshing to be on
the celebrity side for the first time
this is the most fun thing to come out
of the panda usually it's like oh man
they're cancelled but this guy's like
oh my god i actually get a boost for
this yeah